let's hear from people in the audience
we take calls on the friday show via
discord you can find our discord at
davidpakman.com
discord this is free
everyone's welcome to call in discord is
free calling in is free it's all free
i've got nothing to sell you other than
a good time
let's start today
wow
how about nevin from tennessee nevin
welcome nevin you're on the air i heard
a noise so i know you're unmuted welcome
hey
uh i was just asking about
can you hear me
yes i can evan please okay okay thank
you so i was just asking about uh do you
think it's a good strategy for democrats
to infiltrate like republican primaries
to try and get the least radical
candidate nominated like
the um wyoming one with liz cheney do
you think we should go into that primary
vote in it to get liz cheney nominated
over the other guys
yeah it's a case-by-case question in
very so wyoming being so red
the winner of that primary will almost
certainly be the not be the winner so in
that case i think it makes sense there
are other races where it's much tighter
in terms of whether a democrat or a
republican could win and the efforts
would be better served working on
supporting the democratic candidate and
sometimes you can have a situation where
it's better for the republican nominee
to be crazier because it will help the
democrat right so you have to use your
judgment in the liz cheney example it
makes a lot of sense to me
all right thank you that was all i had
to ask how are things in tennessee okay
uh it's a deep red state so
obviously not great but so not great
okay all right we'll keep on keeping on
my friend all right
thank you okay i appreciate the call
there's nevin from tennessee it's deep
red so it's not going that well you hate
to hear that you really do